comment fait-on du miel que faut-il
donner à manger aux oiseaux comment
trier ses déchets à la maison autant de
questions posées aux associations lors
du Forum écologique organisé
spécialement pour les enfants par la
mairie des Clayes-sous-Bois c'est
vraiment mettre le les associations les
professionnels au contact des enfants
pour que chacun puisse échanger les
enfants posent leurs questions les
professionnels répondent grâce à des
jeux des quizz ou encore des ateliers
les associations sensibiliser les
enfants au développement durable et à la
faune et la flore locale on parle des
gestes du quotidien donc ça va du tri
sélectif à tout ce qui touche à
l'alimentation locale donc on les
sensibilise au travail des agriculteurs
aux céréales tout ce qui se passe sur la
plaine de Versailles c'est un jeu de loi
avec des
diverses questions et divers énigmes
pour des séances de reconnaissance
d'espèces des petites anecdotes je leur
ai fait donc découvrir
vous venez le d'où venait le miel quels
étaient des objectifs des abeilles pour
récolter ce nectar donc dans les dans
les fleurs et à quoi servait donc les
abeilles opération réussie au total les
6 centres de loisirs de la commune ce
sont déplacés
du miel on a fait des jeux on a regardé
des oiseaux et des animaux il y avait
des graines qui pouvaient faire venir
les bourdons donc je voulais les planter
à l'école ce forum écologique s'inscrit
sur un programme d'un mois les semaines
du développement durable se termineront
le 15 octobre avec un ciné débat sur le
documentaire ou son passé les lucioles
de Corentin kimeno à l'espace Philippe
Noiret la projection sera suivie d'un
atelier d'initiation à l'astronomie